good afternoon
good afternoon and welcome to this press
conference of the international
observation to the second round of the
presidential election in Tokyo
welcome to those of you who have made it
through the rain as well as those of you
who are joining us online
up here on the podium we have
representatives of the RC parliamentary
assembly the
city of the Council of Europe and the
osc
Organization for Democratic institutions
and human rights we'll begin with brief
statements from up here on the podium
and there will then be time for your
questions
who is special coordinator and leader of
the short-term RC of technician
thank you very much
foreign
[Music]
this afternoon and it is also a pleasure
to see some of your faces again
so let me start by thanking my
colleagues Frank schwaber who is leading
the delegation from parliamentary assami
of Council of Europe and Ambassador
Patterson head of commission here in
European
we are here to announce the main
conclusions of our joint election
observation mission to yesterday's
second round of the presidential
election here in Turkey
I would like to start by thanking all
the Turkish people once again for their
warm welcome in their beautiful country
it was a true pleasure to observe the
general elections and to come for a
second round of the presidential
election at first in the history of
direct presidential elections interview
let me emphasize that the rule of the
law the respectful fundamental rights
and freedoms and the order very
Foundation of a well-functioning
democracy
this interconnected pillars demand our
amazing attention not only on election
days but also Beyond
I will now share our main conclusions
related to the second round of the
presidential election as a continuation
of the statement we delivered after the
first round
the runoff presidential election held on
28th May offered voters a choice between
genuine political alternatives
and want to participation remained High
however as in the first round biased
media coverage and the lack of a Level
Playing Field gave an unjustified
advantage to the incumbent
the election Administration technically
managed the election efficiency but is
lack of transparency and combination
communication largely persisted
why the absence of regulation of several
aspects of the second round did not
provide legal certainty
positively the Supreme election
electoral Council issued multiple
regulations to remedy
some of this
legal gaps
I wonder whether a microphone
conscience
it does
can I continue yes perfect
um in the subtle yet competitive
campaign candidates were able to
campaign freely
however harsher rhetoric
inflammatory and discriminatory Language
by both contestants along with the
continued intimidation and harassment of
supporters of sole proposition parties
undermine the process
in an environment with restrictions on
freedom of expression both private and
public media did not ensure editorial
Independence and impartiality in the
coverage of the campaign
interacting from the ability of Voters
to make an informed drugs
election day itself was generally calm
and well administered however instances
of deficient implementation of certain
procedures particularly during the vote
count were noted
there is much more to say and before I
pass the floor to my colleagues so they
can provide their input please allow me
to sum up my overall impressions
in short our assessment of the second
round of the presidential election is
similar to the one we shared with you
two weeks ago
concerns raised during the first round
over the lack of a Level Playing Field
and the unfairness of the campaign
remained on address
the incumbent president continuing to
benefit from an unjustified advantage
regretfully the use of harmful rhetoric
by post-contestine science that was
discriminatory and inflammatory further
polarized the political environment and
Turkish Society
I would like to upload the Democratic
Spirit demonstrated by the people during
these past weeks
voters came out in Rage numbers
including yesterday and it is crucial
that the winner makes genuine efforts to
ensure the unity of career
We Stand ready to continue to support
and cooperate with the here and its
aspirations to strengthen its democracy
based on the rule of law and respectful
human rights
thank you once again and I will now give
the floor back to you thank you
thank you very much
who heads the delegation From Grace
thank you very much here they are and
good afternoon before I come to the
elections I would like to use the
opportunity since I'm not here as a
German but I am a German
um to remember on the arson attack in
Germany 30 years ago on five
Turkish citizens who were
dead now at the end there were 17 others
Egypt and it was used in insured 27
years I teach against 18 years in
eastern is took 12 years three against
nine years at signed against
for just four years and I really
would like to commemorate those who were
innocently brutally murdered
them Daddy and yours
I think it was necessary on a day like
this now I would like to come to the
elections
and I would like to say as well
like Father our host our host country
and I would like to say that we had some
incidents and it was not easy for some
of us not to go to polling stations in
the first round so it was better now and
I would like to say that there are still
maybe some space for improvement and I
would like to underline that we are here
due to known procedures of our
organization turkey is under monitoring
and because of this we were here all
together with around 40 people over the
two rounds in this round with 20 people
and I would like to say for sure
for the very very good cooperation we
are not able to monitor elections
without you and it's very good that
knowing that we have sometimes different
things to do and to look into different
things International elections that we
cooperate
final statement here all together
the second round of the presidential
elections has resulted in a clear winner
this we have to say nevertheless the
second round also took place like the
restaurant in the environment that in
many ways does not provide the
conditions for holding Democratic
elections turkey must now implement
and a real life to strength is the
judgments of the European Court of Human
Rights and above all release of San
Carlos
in the future of the Supreme election
Council must be committed to the
greatest possibly possible transference
in order to strengths and Trust in the
electoral process so I really would like
to underline that finally we we have the
same situation like in the in the first
round so we have always to look on the
election day and again there is a very
clear winner this is what we have to say
on this election day but we have to look
into the environment Democratic
environment in the country as well and
there it is like two weeks ago that we
have to describe the immediate situation
as very limited that we see a lot of
journalists in prison and that we see a
situation that causes censorship in this
country and on the ranking of reporters
with our border third year is on one of
the last places in the world in the
world ranking
the same time we have the
difficult situation for the opposition
we have the former co-chair of the hap
in prison we have the closing procedures
about hdp and we have a ruling against
the mayor of anger Earth of istanbulu
where at the end may be prevent him for
running as a candidate as president in
this country
but at the same time people voted again
and a lot of people who go to vote again
and we have a very high turnout again
and they could express their opinion and
at the end if somebody asked me if this
was the people throw into The Ballot Box
is this what they count at the end and
this is the result of the elections and
I would say yes it is with some problems
yes we saw the problems but finally
that's the outcome physics at the end
first I really would like to urge
as well to refrain after the campaign
from violence speeches sales speeches
about against minorities whether it's
lgbtiq one from one side of the
political Spectrum or if it's what we
unfortunately saw the second one from
the other side of the political cycle
second I really would like to to rush
the central electoral Council and those
who are responsible those were the
lawmakers to follow the recommendations
of the events commission and to do
everything to be as transparent as
it was very important in a country where
some mistrust in this intellectual
procedure that there is a lot of
transparency events organization and
finally I have to strengthen again in
line with the outcome of the summit of
the heads of states and governments of
our organization Council of Europe
United League who met between the first
round and the second round of the
turkey has to implement like other all
other countries the judgments and the
rulings of the European Court of human
rights that need they have to release
and Trust Osman Canada because we are in
a procedure under article
46.1 we have to proceed on this thank
you very much
thank you finally we lost but not least
thank you very much and uh let me join
you this is welcoming you to this press
conference and thank you for your
continued interest in our observation
mission
before I talk about our findings I would
like to thank the Turkish authorities
for their invitation to observe and I
would also like to thank our partners
here in the international election
observation Mission from the OC
parliamentary assembly as well as the
Parliamentary assembly on the Council of
Europe for the ongoing and excellent
cooperation
I've been in
tortilla with a team of election experts
since late March
which has given us a considerable period
in which to
closely observe the results to both
grounds of the elections
for the last two weeks we have continued
our conversations with states of issues
as well as witnessing society and I've
observed the work of the election
Administration as well as a tone and
substance of the campaign
important aspect of our observation is
our ongoing media analysis which to
which I will return shortly
and with nearly 806 Guild service spread
out across the country for the second
round it has been possible for us to
make its statistical assessment of the
voting process of the election day
following our observations on this
second round of presidential election
I'd like to go into a few points more in
detail
first of all I like it once again to
congratulate the people of turkey for
turning out the vote in such high
numbers
citizens were able to choose between
real political Alternatives in
yesterday's runoff and the campaign
period was mostly peaceful
they came in the head of the second
round was more low-key the underground
up to the first round although it picked
up as election day near and candidates
were able to campaign the campaign
freely
the election of the session led by the
Supreme electoral Council member's
preparation for the second round
efficiently in the short time frame at
the same time as finalizing the
Parliamentary world
this is to be commented
however the lack of transparency of
circle in the first round continued with
a national election authorities holding
closed sessions and with holding the
publication of most decisions
including on complaints related to the
first round results
this was a coronary trust in his work
which is key to Citizens confidence in
the entire electoral system
language use in the campaign over the
last two weeks
has been polarized and hot with
accusations on collaboration with
various organization by both political
camps in the same period I know very
concerned super episode some opposition
parties continue to face intimidation
and harassment
the prosecution not only San Lucas
continue the head of the second round
and the included cases based on the
legal prohibition
of insulting public officials further
leading freedom of expressing
this is most describing and it cannot be
emphasized enough of important this
freedom is for democracy
my final point
one of the two front points concerned
media bias which was created in the
first round and continued to be so ahead
of the second
as I mentioned earlier media monitoring
is an integral part of our observation
that many broadcasters did not meet the
legal obligation to provide a partial
coverage of the campaign
neither did they give equal
opportunities to the two presidential
candidates with the public broadcaster
significantly favoring the incumbent and
the same revised notice in numerous
drivers media objects
the majority of these Central causes
also often blur the distinction between
facts and opinions in their news
coverage selective representing the
coverage in favor of a particular
candidate
my second Point fun point is election
day which itself will also most peaceful
although they were isolated instances of
violence that were mostly directed
against opposition supporters
observes also not in cases of group or
family routing while the secrecy of the
workload's potential compromise due to
the layout or subcommunications
one of the presence of Market service
and Civil Society Representatives or
positive their activities were hidden in
numerous cases
family and under a procedure
shortcomings were also during the count
the hundred points I have I just
mentioned are some of the most important
from our ongoing observation because yes
indeed I am the team of experts will
remain in Turkey for several days still
to observe after the month of the
election and and how any complaints or
appeals are dealt with
for many of the aspects or our
observation I would recommend that you
take a copy of a report together with a
press release on your way out and you
will find some interesting things in
that report
[Music]
spread out across the country
without you there will be will be no
connection observation thank you very
much
um there's no time for your questions as
this is a press conference we will only
be taking questions from journalists
therefore be grateful if you click Again
by introducing yourself and your media
after before asking your question
so you're welcome to ask questions in
English or in Turkish
are there any questions from Russell
interesting
thank you um
1889 and those Charmed by the way you
would see uh
husband and wife with their children
March into the following sessions
it was sort of the election was an
occasion for family acting
and I think this is one of the aspects
making for such a high turnout in
Turkish elections however you are
raising objections to family voting
say if husband and wife and
adults daughter or adult son goes to
vote in Booth all together what do you
expect Napoleon officials to do
to say Hey you know
the three of you take a break
one by one or something like that
what is your objection to family protein
the other thing is I want to know
something about there were objections
raised
about alleged irregularities in the
first round
did you find that the Supreme electoral
Council
aggressively pursued those objections
in Turkey we often think that the
Supreme electoral council is too laid
back
when it comes to the main start
regularities what is your impression of
the way they respond to allegations of
irregularities
foreign
and I think it's pretty easy to avoid it
actually for the election official to
gently tell the people how they should
be done and I'm not actually sure that
we'll go very well indeed they are
learning because coming to the same
public stations and I guess it will be
pretty easy to do it according to the
rules and still need that very nice
family outing as yourself suggested so I
don't think
on the on the second question it's a
little bit difficult at this stage to
say because the the process has not yet
been finalized we have not yet had the
official numbers out in spite of
on the 28th of May we will have the fun
results on the
the frozen tree the road elections and
we as a student we have stayed quietly
in our
in our report that we have a concerns
about the transparency we are simply not
given the decision and the openness
which we which we need so we are still
waiting and as I said we are going to
stay in the country for about a week so
I guess we'll have a better answer to
the question when we see their decisions
and I would like to add also to the
point
indeed criticize also the lack of
transparency
Administration strongly in our first
segment
we have locally the opportunity of
meeting the
chairman of
SEC and
and community members on last Friday
um and this is a very good beginning of
a conversation I think that I hope we
will be able to continue that and uh to
see how really the transparency of
collection Administration could be
higher I think this has learned at least
from this this election
that there is a little bit difference
between the first part a very personal
and second round we saw in second round
some improvement and we hope that that
will be actually continued
just to prevent a misunderstanding about
family voting that doesn't mean that you
make a nice trip or whatever the family
to the polling stations in Germany I
always take my children and they can
even go and look what I'm doing that
they should understand how people
Democratic procedures
there's one part of the family mostly a
man
who tried to let's say lead all the
others and to show them where they have
to make him on the crosses the same
that's the situational that you have a
situation where it obviously it looks
like one shave of the family and he
shows all the others what to do and this
is what happened and what we witness in
some cases and what we want to program
for the future
are you saying you're objecting to more
than one family member going into the
polling booth at the same time that I
quite understand yes but it sounds from
Mr Peterson that he didn't like
husband's wife and another child going
to the polling station at the same time
then I didn't clean these up because I
just mentioned the family voting I think
I mentioned it once and I think we all
know what it means that is
so I didn't make any other reference to
this so so I may have agree with that
I'm not quite sure how I was unclear but
anyway even told us
thank you
Jesus actually
um
[Music]
foreign
one of the aspects of legislations I
think the uh how can we say fabricated
footage of the presence Mr Aaron about a
leakage
so-called leakage of the CHP leader in
chemical show with the
Tourist Organization tkk I think you
follow these footage videos and present
add-on actually accepted that these
Hooters are the Montage
so how do you observe this Evolutions
about act this
discussions
and did you add this topic in your
report in coming weeks
if I understand correctly you are
referring to the room of fake news
or not fake news and painful
exactly fake fake videos and really
trying to make videos
I think you Mr Peterson can actually
elaborate on this whole media monetary
but before that I would like emphasize
we are very much critical about this
polarized language used and actually
from both sides
accusations
inflammatory language discriminatory
language and I think now the actions are
over and there is
dinner
the thing that's really
needs a lot of care and also healing if
you want in the in the society because
it it deepens a lot the the division in
the society and I think this is
something that really needs attention
and we hope
to be and to see it in the coming weeks
and months that that atmosphere and that
landscape actually changes
thank you very much uh I think I know
what you're talking about that also very
specific uh incident
our report
will be based on factual observations
but that does not mean that we have to
that it is possible to give all the
facts in the reports the important thing
is that we have a factual background for
what we are are doing when it comes to
the to the what we are also serving and
recommending
what we say in the report is that the
obligation to our connections and to
terrorist organizations is something
that we heard from a box of science we
are not going into concrete arguments on
the complete incidents in
but the the issue using the terrorist
aggregation is one which we are dealing
with
if we have the obligation to go into or
mention all the concrete incidents it
will be a pretty long report and it is
necessarily not necessary to get through
our main conclusions so sometimes we
have a concrete examples but that is
just unlocking our general observations
so you shouldn't put too much into where
it is whether it is not mentioned in
other photons
as an organization we really strongly
condemn all kinds of terrorism we really
have to ask each and everyone to be
careful to reduce others to be connected
to terrorism about the specific appear
you spoke about I think one problem is
not just that the video was produced the
other problem is that it was used or
shown in the media with no comments
added I would understand that we should
have a media situation in the country
where they really try to explain the
video and to criticize it as well in a
way but if you have a biased area
situation where the media just take the
video without any comments on it then
it's it's really a concerned and a
problem and this is in the world
description we have learned about about
the whole media situation of the country
are there any more questions from the
floor
to see if I'm in online
yes this question has come on online
questions coming do you have enough
evidence after two rounds with the same
shortcomings to conclude whether the
elections were both free and third
I kind of start by saying that
um you know a complex situation like a
decision where we are in in in Intercare
with this enormous participation of uh
of of of the people of turkey and with
our
really
understanding that the people had the
choice between genuine political
alternatives
um it is very very
short-sighted to end up by just saying
it was fair or it was not fair because
it was free or it was not free I think
we have to take into account into
account the complexity the the the the
different actually uh observations that
we did from the beginning till end I
think we have been very clear about that
there was unfair on unjustifying
actually advantages for the incumbent
president and for the ruling parties
because especially also of media bias
because of this
media coverage because of the lack of
access to Media by the opposition
because of that some political actually
people were
facing
legal problems for seclusion and so on
yes this has all been part of this
process by putting on a label would be
difficult because it has all these
actually elements in it
we
elections are terms of complex
process with and if you see how many
ports you can see that some of it we
have a positive evaluation software
rather negative evaluation depending on
which part of the process we we focus on
and that is why we always avoid getting
sweeping one-liners because that is
simply not doing Justice to the complex
process that we have seen so I I
absolutely agree with what you said but
since my my
team is responsible for for the
observations I must say that for those
conclusions which we put in into our
neighbor time well I I was like I yes I
think we have enough background for
giving these assessments not enough
evidence sometimes we would like to have
more more evidence then we are careful
in our investment but where we are have
clear recommendations and clear
confidence yes I think we have enough
say the question how to describe an
election with one or two words is
difficult
and but for sure if I would ask my
children if there are two teams playing
football and one team have shoes at the
others not when they say it's fair on
not I don't know so it's
it's not easy to describe it when you
don't want to do it with with content
and so I fully understand that we have
this long-term obligation Mission and we
have so many things to evaluate so we
don't want to reduce it on one or two
words but I would like to underline what
I what I said in my in my statement
nevertheless the second round also took
place in an environment in many ways
does not provide the conditions for
holding regulations so I think it's
critical enough to describe it but again
there is much more than to describe it
just for transcendants
[Music]
live with me
a question for Visa masterpieces and you
met with the management of rtsc and trt
how would you comment about those
meetings with a transparent to give you
the answer you asked and
verifiable answers
to the broadcast in Turkey had coronate
with the answer that you got from them
I will not go into all individual
meetings we had a characterization I
think the important thing is will be the
conclusions we have in our report and
you will see from our report that we
have a critical
comments on the media situation actually
that is one of the
[Music]
so I refer you to the report as radio
so if there are enough further questions
from the floor
then we would stop here
as well as the statement my colleagues
are mentioning under press release which
are outside on the table for you in both
English and Turkish I would like to
mention the fact there's probably two to
three months from now we will be
publishing a final report summarizing
all of our observation which will also
contain recommendations to the
authorities how to improve the situation
for the next time so you may want to
keep on an eye out for that um for the
answers to your questions in the longer
term thank you very much